I Cleveland's finest giving us a ride
they all I got a gunman Obama's got
something he's gonna cure you power
partying there were partying Cleveland
we gotta study girl and with a fan we
gonna [ __ ] some [ __ ] up George Michael
more powerful than a Taser all right
thank you my friend do we want to go
right for the limp I'm friend brother
appreciate you laugh do the robot right
on the tab we're but can we put this on
the Internet
place the bonus it's just fatar tartare
you got to go in and steal this and
clean up and throwing [ __ ] stick your
fists up somebody did I'll just try to
paint a picture partnership material
because every time I hear Brie footage
of the great media's that I love hey
turn on the internet and Dumber era but
a big by the boat a good buy new stuff
you caught you staring at your food dude
and you look at me and I was really
uncomfortable in you go you want a
shrimp is offered me a shrimp ah not a
great start oh it's not a great story
that you are a lesser comedian of big
fried shrimp a better-looking first of
all the only know how that might never
ever exhibited you shut the [ __ ] up
right the only time ever there are four
eva eva know that right over what boss
to one of my shaft no that's what a win
is everything I bet you off with your
blue really good hahaha you really
didn't offer me I didn't feel like I
could have the shrimp I wanted something
if you were just trying to get me to
stop staring at you don't know what an
amazing i damned entertainer the whole
story just sounds so black you know what
I didn't like about you tonight the
chili
no I want to know his neck was an old
vic fit that i really didn't like thank
you now what was it where are you i'm
totally [ __ ] kid I'm acting I feel I
go to the girl fashion show see you then
I was a baby
we saw the peppers on the last two or
three times hey we just amazing and I'm
afraid to see it without Frusciante it
really does I'm nervous about really
yeah because i love rashad a yeah yeah
really doing is [ __ ] style and what
he brought totally and but the new guy
he likes to be great and even down here
just son by you what they just came up
here to have a private party like just
[ __ ] walk down here yeah we got a
camp bring it on my friend all right
basically children and that's me you
interesting for you know take it easy
man you guys all right i watch kids
every mother in Pearl the other day why
should I bother you captain tom kills
that God loves you so much she can't
stand to come the same NASA totally
ridiculous that she watching the kitchen
and when she did broke up to my stomach
and said I can every base at the same
time